leader of baba district council and will
be chairing this meeting may i remind
you of some domestic arrangements
please ensure that you maintain social
distancing from all other persons whilst
in the chamber and in the communal areas
please ensure that you wear a face
covering at all times unless you're
sitting down or if you're exempt from
doing so and that you use the hand
sanitizer and wipes provided
please ensure that microphones are
turned off when not in use
please do not interrupt other speakers
or hold separate conversations whilst
others are speaking
if you are attending the meeting to
speak and persistently interrupt the
meeting you may be asked to leave
please ensure your mobile phones are on
silent or switched off
and finally we'll be using e-voting for
this meeting on the modern.gov app so
please can members make sure they are
logged in and ready to use the app
i'd like to remind everyone present this
meeting will be broadcast live to the
internet and will be capable of repeated
viewing the whole of the meeting will be
filmed except whether our confidential
or exempt items
if you make a representation to the
meeting you will be deemed by the
council to have consented to be filmed
by entering this meeting as a speaker
you are also consenting to being
recorded by the council and to the
possible use of those images and sound
recordings for webcasting and all
training purposes
the council members of the public and
the press may record film photograph
will broadcast this meeting when the
public and the press are not lawfully
excluded
before i move to the agenda
i would like to have just a minutes
silent reflection for the victims of the
atrocities in ukraine
okay we'll now move on to the agenda
item one apologies for absence
thank you chair we have received
apologies from council holt and also the
assistant director for planning and
building control thank you
item two to review uh to receive
declarations of pecuniary and
non-pecuniary interests by members are
there any to declare
nope
right um item three paper bca 2140
minutes of last month's meeting will
defer until next month there's still a
number of matters that need to be
resolved before we're in a position to
propose and agree these minutes
item 4 to receive notification of
petitions in accordance with the
council's petition scheme
non-received chair thank you
item five questions by councillors
non-received chair
and item six matters referred by the
overview and scrutiny or joint audit and
standards
committees i'll understand council
mclaren you wish to
say something thank you chair
um
you have in front of you the draft
minutes of the calling on the 21st of
february 2022
which i hope you have read
however chair there's just one or two
things i'd like to add
um
the coast signatories we actually left
off the minutes and i think it's
important that people know who the
co-signatories were to the calling
that was councillors melanie barrett
trevor cresswell mick fraser
jane gould margaret mabry and mark
newman
basically the call-in was about three
things
the lack of detail within the proposed
expenditure of 150 000
um because it was over 150 000 it was a
key decision
and so
uh the signatory felt there was a
requirement for the cabinet to explore
all circumstances surrounding that
decision
and there was also a lack of in-depth
questioning into the various aspects of
the 150k by cabinet members as it was a
public forum
chair in addition to this i would like
to draw the cabinet's attention to the
options that were open to the committee
which many members may
be familiar with or not
there was three
and the first one refer the matter back
to the cabinet for reconsideration
together with the observations of the
overview and scrutiny committee
cabinet will then take a final decision
and that decision cannot be called in
the second option
will seek the advice of the monitoring
officer as to whether the decision is
contrary to
or not wholly in accordance with the
policy framework
or the budget and if
applicable refer the matter to full
council for a final decision
option three
that the decision be upheld and
implemented
immediately
we were advised by the monitoring
officer at the meeting that option two
was not applicable
and option one
sort of
really stopped any further calling
so
at the end of the debate
the committee resolved
that the decision held
the decision taken by cabinet be upheld
and implemented immediately thank you
thank you council mclaren for that
moving on
item seven uh the forthcoming decisions
list you've all
had
an opportunity to see this does anyone
have any questions on the forthcoming
decisions list
if not then
the decisions list is noted as it is
thank you
item eight paper
bca2141 the general revenue account
financial monitoring um for 21 to 22
quarter three and i'll now invite the
cabinet member for finance to introduce
this report
council barrett
um uh thank you very much uh yes we have
a presentation
um of the quarter three out term
position which i think rebecca is coming
sorry cathy
no apologies the cabinet member usually
introduces sorry
so you have to forgive me i'm still on
thai times so
right so the recommendation uh that we
have before you
um is the recommendation three three
four one three point two three point
three um basically given the quarter
three out term position which currently
stands at a surplus of 741
000
you'll see that is made up in appendix a
with the variances that are duly noted
these
variances um
obviously make up a lot the big ones
that probably worth noting are the
planning and development um extra income
coming in from that which has been
favorable
again
also on that side there is um
a deficit in the
the amount of uh
labor or
wages
or salaries because of the reduction in
the numbers and we've seen an overall
we're about 15 percent
overall
down on our normal position
had every
everyone being filled
but uh that is an ongoing and it has
been decreased it was 17 so we've seen
the two percent reduction we have made
appointments in the subsequent period uh
and that's obviously in terms of uh that
will reduce that over a period of time
i think the the the good thing though is
that we are we are seeing
that the budgets
uh
in certain areas
are are accurate but there's just those
anomalies there we should create this
741 surplus
i think what i'd like to
it depends where we end up in quarter
four but if we carry on that trajectory
we should be
seeing uh
probably into the pattern near the
million mark
so um
i would like to propose that we
note this and he's only for noting
and that's
item 3 3.1 3.2 3.3 and
can i have a second to please
council busby
thank you
okay um
so uh questions does any cabinet member
have any questions on this
council busby
yeah i'm concerned about the level of
staff vacancies uh
15 is pretty high
i just wanted to know
what percentage of our total underspend
the
741 000
is due to
uh reduction in staffing costs because
of the vacancies
i couldn't find anything related to the
money on that
there's one
but it's there is a table there which
shows that the actual 15 i think if you
look at 6.7 on the staff latencies
it does give you the vacancy rate and
the grand total
it doesn't no it doesn't give an amount
there's a big number to be um
underspent but if it's 739 000 that is
due to the fact that we haven't filled
15 of our staff positions then it isn't
such a big number is it uh it's not that
it's not that great the actual staff
percentages are there um in terms of
where the money is if you look at the um
appendix a you see the difference
and i think the majority you've got 300
of a thousand in the planning side then
there's a combination of staff shortages
which you'll see in the bracketed
figures
just
they don't add up to the vast amount
it's just collectively that
obviously we have got shortages
it's it's not it's not the major
where most of the money's come from
oh i don't know about that i think i'd
probably question that if you've got 15
percent of your staff i defer
catherine could you
give some support on that one because
i'm i don't think i think overall there
is i say it's 15 but in numbers but uh
i'm not sure what it actually is in the
pound shooting pens i don't think i've
got the definitive figure but there's a
couple of bits i can perhaps add
when we were just looking at the changes
from q2 to q3 i know that an extra 200
000
is due to the the staff vacancies and
the other factor within this is that we
do have a five percent vacancy factor
within the budget anyway so
five percent is already accounted for in
the budget so it would be that extra bit
over and above that is attributed to the
savings
we would need to go back i think just to
see if we can put an absolute figure
you'll see in appendix a there's quite a
few different service areas talk about
their savings so it might be a case we
might just need to go through and add
those up and then take off the vacancy
factor that we hold we hold centrally so
we'll do that outside of the meeting and
let you know the answer
councilman crore did you have something
exactly the point i was about to make in
appendix a if you start off with
communities and well-being you can see
that
the reasons the comments given in the
final column uh 165 000 in staff
vacancies for community development if
you go further down the table you'll
find some places where there are net
increases in staff and agency costs
there are
a variety of these sectors
indicate that there has been an
underspend in staffing and as it
suggested you could add them all
together economy and business fifty
three thousand four towns visit
envisioning twenty one thousand
um licensing staff costs
um then there's an agency cost to cover
a vacant post sort of alistair can i
stop it because that isn't the only
reason for that variance in that
particular line it's not all down to
staff costs not at all but it is an
indicator and i'm pretty sure that
i won't give you the answer to the
question that i asked
okay
it's an indicator it's all i'm saying
that's all we can have at this stage i
think
council barry did you want to say
something more
yeah i mean despite that i mean we're
still functioning okay as a council it's
just that and there's also you have to
take into account the certain amount of
churn that you'll always get with within
the staffing positions
so uh
that will affect depending what quarter
it is if it falls within the quarter
it's not so bad but if it falls outside
one quarter in another you'll then see
that effect coming through
thank you
any other questions from anyone
council busby
on page 36
there's um so i wasn't quite sure of it
related to
it says um
where is it now uh
on law and governance electoral services
and land charges there's an information
management line which says that income
from hmlr
for transferring llc one to work to
central location we've saved seventy
five thousand pounds
i
didn't understand a word of that line if
somebody could explain it to me in words
of one syllable please emily
yeah okay yeah that's to do with land
charges yeah yeah
yeah thanks
thank you chair um so this is to do with
part of the land charges search being
transferred um to uh now being dealt
with essentially by the land registry
and as part of that they awarded um
unring fenced new burdens funding to
local authorities as part of that data
transfer so that's the leftover sum
after we've taken out our costs of
preparing the data for transfer
well that's just a one-off that's
getting you next year
okay
do you have another one
somebody's read the papers yeah i've got
a question as well in a minute and
on on reserves we've got a table of
general uh reserves i just wondered
whether we could combine some of them
it's there are some that
are related
um for instance we've got um
rough sleeping temporary accommodation
homelessness
i wonder whether those could be
combined
into one reserve
um we've got two lots of planning okay
they're slightly different
just to
make the table smaller but make the the
reserves more flexible in their use
the the rough sleeping i think probably
needs to be separate i think that was a
separate heading because it came in as a
separate one-off payment so i think
that's why that's there
um as a separate heading i think that
was government money that came directly
it was ring fence just purely for that
benefit so that's why that's like that
i i
understand that but i mean
the difference between rough sleeping
and homelessness
is thin the trouble is you get to a
position where you can over
give too much information or not enough
but i think
when you have a separate line in
a report especially for something like
that where it's been funded as an
outside body not necessary from our i
think you do need to show that and i
think quite a few of these do suffer
from that type of uh reserve type nature
so
i agree with what he's saying in that
general area it'd be easier just to put
it as one but i think because they are
separate income streams coming into the
council i think they have to be shown
separately
yeah we've had a number of grants from
the government for rough sleeping and
homelessness to tackle specific things
and to allow us to do specific things
um
and that they are uh
we do need to keep that money separate
as indeed we need to keep the uh
the reserve for temporary accommodation
separate although
i i take your point it's it's all
to do with the same sort of thing but um
uh there's uh completely separate
activities with separate sources of
funding and um
while rough sleeping is a form of
homelessness that homelessness is is far
wider than rough sleeping so we do need
to keep them separate
and elections fund and elections
equipment
i'm not sure what does anyone uh
catherine do emily
i'll um happily take that question again
chair um so the elections fund is for
the um annual
reserve
contribution that's made every year over
four years and then it's spent in the
fourth year when we actually have an
election so the cost is built up on on
an annual basis and spent in the fourth
year and the election equipment reserve
is
there for um
whenever we have to uh outlay on new uh
replacement ballot boxes or something
like that so if we have to make a large
purchase of replacement election
equipment um the money is there to fund
that and then we're able to recover part
of that cost from national elections so
when we make claims for national
elections we can um
claim back a proportion
over the life span of that piece of
equipment
um i've just got one
quick question of my own um
6.17
and i can't quite reconcile the the
numbers there that
in the capital program uh relating to
sil and section 106 monies with um the
corresponding numbers in appendix e
i was just wondering if um
anyone can
provide some clarity on that please
uh council barrack or catherine um 27
for 6.17 and appendix e is on um
page
uh page 43 for a penalty
not the uh the overall um
uh
adverse variants for the capital program
but just specifically uh the items
relating to uh sill still funding and um
there's section 106 monies
in appendix e yeah but at
6
17. it um refers to
all right let me go back here again
uh
505 four
no no 318 is fine um but the 505 related
to the civil funding um and 362 for
section 106 monies
stated in 617
but in appendix e
that the numbers are different
catherine are you able to so i think
we'll take that offline and look at the
detail rather than holding up cabinets
so yeah okay thanks thank you
um no more questions from the cabinet uh
council mclaren do you have a question
thank you jeff
mine's about staff vacancies as well
um
the statement that the average vacancy
rate at to the end of november's 12
is a bit misleading because then when
you look at the detail
i think for the
community's housing and law and
governance the
vacancy rate is
important and so my question
is um
do we have co do we have comparisons
with the figures for 2019
and
what do we think is contributing to the
vacancies is it the
dearth of suitable candidates
or the employment package is not
competitive
thank you joe
oh thank you council mclaren
i think i would refer that to the chief
exec
because
i had a feeling that was coming my way
in terms of the comparisons to previous
years yes we will have it i don't have
that to hand unless unless catherine
happens to do but i suspect not but we
can certainly get that outside of the
meeting in terms of reasons for
vacancies it will vary massively so it
will be the reasons that you gave
but it will be other things as well
percentages of course could be slightly
misleading because in a small team
one vacancy makes a large percentage uh
equally in a large team um that
percentage will be more concerning so
housing for example may be more
concerning because overall that's a
large service area but when you then
drill into where those vacancies are
within that broader service area they
may again be in relatively small teams
so
damsel damn lies analyzing statistics i
suppose and we do need to be careful of
that but in terms of reasons for
vacancies um yes wages are an issue and
you
have heard the conversation around that
previously and i'm sure we'll have that
again and there's a commitment from
myself to to carry out a pay review for
all staff to look at salaries um the
wider employment market is an issue and
you will have heard not just in local
government but in all sectors the
numbers of vacancies and the difficulty
people are having to recruit there are
simply more jobs than people
which creates challenge for local
government as it does in all other areas
um following the pandemic what people
are looking for has changed as well so
that the options around flexibility for
example and certainly we we provide a
good package there so we're an
attractive employer in that regard but
people can work by and large where they
want in the country and one of the
challenges and benefits of local
government is that we're everywhere and
so somebody can be working here and then
relocate to cornwall and still be
working in local government which again
presents a challenge for us overall and
then the other element i suppose i'd
just draw out is
the way in which we are set up in terms
of the length of time that people have
to give as a notice period versus the
length of time it takes to recruit
somebody
they very rarely overlap nicely um so
inevitably when somebody leaves it takes
us longer to fill that post than it
would uh to to before they've left
um but we are employing more people
overall than we have in the past uh and
obviously we've chewed people in more
recently through uh bringing in the
contract around public realm um and so
again
things appear in our stats that might
not previously have appeared in our
stats but it doesn't mean they weren't
happening before but you're just seeing
it in a consolidated approach but it's
it's all of the above absolutely
check can i just ask one final question
thank you
um
i noticed that there was um
i think
costs for temporary staff are
highlighted do we have a figure for the
whole of the council
of what
agency and temporary staff cost do we
have a total amount is it if i missed it
in the papers
i don't know whether it was in papers
and i can i'll defer to my finance
colleagues on the right but yes we do
it's monitored on a monthly basis
exactly in terms of external staff that
we're using and equally whether they are
supernumerary so extra posts that aren't
otherwise on our books or whether they
are people that have come in on a
temporary basis to fill vacancies that
are on our books um overall over a
period of time we've used fewer far
fewer uh external people which is a good
thing because broadly speaking is
expensive um to to use external people
in that way on an interim basis
and also it's not really helpful in the
grand scheme of things we want to retain
people and build up build up cultures
internally but there are times where
it's entirely appropriate to do so um
an example and only because elections
was mentioned earlier every year we
carry out the elections canvas um those
people would show up as being external
people because they come in for a short
period of time in order to do
door-to-door canvas for a period of time
they probably aren't the kind of things
you're talking about yes we do monitor
on a monthly basis happy to provide
outside the meeting if it's not
otherwise i'm glancing across no it's
not so it's not in the papers in front
of you but we can provide that
thank you arthur thank you
okay thank you uh i'll now open this up
for debate uh does any cabinet member
wish to say anything about the
general fund report
um
only that um
the uh obviously carried forward which
is in a position is a good position to
be in
um
again i think this what we're trying to
do with the budget that we've just had
presented was to try and get the budget
in a more accurate position to reflect
where we are and this is exactly where
we're seeing if we looked at the other
pessimistic view of the budget that we
had
last year and now in our out turn
position i think what we're trying to do
is get that into more accurate position
again though it is it just highlights
the problem uh most of the time our
expenses are fairly accurate we know
where we are with those
it's the income streams that we can't
predict and it does show up and this is
actually showing up here of how much
that does affect the overall position of
the council
yeah um
i
i fully understand and concur with that
and that of course has been exacerbated
over the past couple of years with the
coving situation in terms of um
the the government grants and and uh the
impact on other income streams as well
so um but uh in any event what we've got
here is still a good picture and it's a
good position to be in and we'll be able
to do something useful with this uh
surplus when
just to come back i mean if if this was
reflected in and we knew that this was
going to be the surplus in the next
say three or four years then if you look
at our medium term financial position
which shows a 2.3 million deficit then
that deficit would be turned on its head
and we'd be in a neutral position but we
can't take that at its face value at the
moment so this is why it's uh
it's slightly frustrating and i think
the sooner that we can actually get a
three-year settlement from the
government at any one time which would
give us a far better position to be able
to budget in a more accurate way
absolutely and every council in the
country it's pressing for that
okay then um
if there's uh if there's no further uh
comments then uh
we'll move to the vote uh can we open
the vote please henry yet
certainly chair members the vote is now
in progress
councillor dawson are you still having
problems logging on
and councilman vasey are you still
are you able to vote
electronically
counselor possibly
have you voted
chair that's uh nine votes four
thank you
paper bca
the hra financial monitoring for 21 to
22 quarter three and i'll invite the
cabinet member for finance to introduce
this report council uh castle barrett
could be councillor busby
thank you members um yes just uh go we
have the quarter three out term for the
hra account as in your report
one three recommendation
two
um
the point to note
and this is for noting uh is that um
the out turn has got worse from the
quarter two which is four nine nine
we're now at six 617 as deficit again
this is mainly caused by the
increased charges for the
housing repair bills
again in the future budget this has been
amended and increased
i think this is more to do with the
budget being inaccurate
and also the effect of covid which has
increased our costs
which has caused this but apart from
that the overall position is as per we
would expect so i'd ask for a recommend
sorry ask for a second to please
council roswell in a second thank you
okay questions anyone
come from rvc
thank you thank you chair um
in the light of recent events
and the fact that post-covered
raw materials and building materials
especially have sharply risen
are you making extra allowances in the
budget for that moving forward
within the the budget there is an extra
half a million pound been put in so
effectively if you take this deficit and
the other one there's almost
from i think i'm rightly saying sort of
equates to about a million pounds
um if you take we'll actually be more
than that now because the deficit's gone
up so we we have allowed for it but but
also um
one of the other things that will
hopefully uh kick in
is the the
training that's going on uh to the
housing repair teams so there's less use
of subcontractors but i think gavin
would you like to give an update on that
thank you councillor barrett um you're
correct in terms of the um increase in
in the budget that uh
full council agreed in in february will
support i think approximately a 15
uplift on the
building services uh responsive repairs
and maintenance budget uh that's in
light of a very comprehensive review of
the budget um and expenditure over the
past four years so incorporating not
only code but the year's
proceeding
and as such we hear that the proposed
budget for for 22 23 is more realistic
um and achievable
even with uh inflationary increases or
rises in in material spend
just as an aside to the reasons that you
have set out
in front of you at 6.10
we have been looking at building
services in more detail in recent weeks
and as an example
of why you'll be seeing a an adverse
variance for this year um this figure is
for babe mid-suffolk combined so i
apologize i don't have the baby figure
but um up to the end of q3
we had undertaken more than 100
additional voids
in comparison to the year 2019-20
and that was still with a further
quarter
remaining
now on the basis that each void costs
between three and four thousand pounds
um you can immediately see that
expenditure will have risen by uh nearly
four hundred thousand just just through
uh additional voids um and those
additional voids which invariably uh
result in significant works being
undertaken um no one can predict or or
or uh plan for for the number of voids
they will be subject to a number of
reasons such as uh sadly the death of a
tenant or transfer to care or transfer
to a new property and clearly as a
council with ambitions to build and
acquire more and more properties you'll
naturally see uh residents move uh and
transfer as well so um just it's just
additional uh to support that adverse
variance this year
thank you gavin
any other questions
i've got one um
6.11
in the table at the top of page 49.
we're now
talking about the transfer from the
strategic priorities reserve
of 10 000 sorry
10.439 million
um and it it indicates that that's in
the the budget transferred from column
this is the first uh paper that we've
seen this number it wasn't in the budget
back in uh february last year and it
wasn't in the quarter one and quarter
two monitoring papers
can can anyone provide an explanation
please
that i will happily transfer
to uh
catherine
struggling just to find the right uh
section in the report but um i believe
it's to do with capital funding from the
reserve so to support
so it's an extra revenue contribution
towards capital coming from the
strategic priorities reserve
for housing
thank you i thought that might be the
case it's just that um
this particular table at the top of the
page is the only place that the number
is mentioned yes i think we haven't
shown it previously i think we did when
we put the budget paper together and
then i realized we weren't being
consistent with what we were showing in
the budget monitoring report so we've
brought that
made it consistent now with this report
right okay because uh it is
significantly different obviously from
the budget paper from just over a year
ago
it's
yes although we would have been
earmarking some of the funding from a
reserve for
for the capital uh then but yeah so it
was probably an error in how we showed
that table at the time okay thank you
thanks
council mclaren do you have a question
no thank you chair
i'll now open this paper up for debate
cabinet members does anyone wish to to
comment any further i know we we talked
um
quite a bit about the
um
the
increased costs in in the buildings and
renovations and maintenance program but
is there anything else anyone wants to
talk about
in which case then
oh council busby well i think it was
bringing up here on the performance
report um
so i'll do it here uh housing
association we've got we've got 3443
houses how many houses do housing
association have
in our district roughly
any idea
every association every registered
provider is is different naturally
if you combined our stock with mid
suffix and look at it as
as a total sum uh we're comparable to
uh all well housing and and have
rehousing locally
i was trying to establish how many
houses are either council
and or affordable
i.e assuming the affordable ones have
gone to the housing association
is it 10 of the total housing in the
area which no it's more than that
because
we have 10 of council houses
it's not a figure that i've got to hand
but i'm happy to go away and and bring
that back to you it's obviously not
crucial it's just that
my mind was thinking we we demand 35
affordable housing
from new developments
why don't we take those affordable
housing
and convert them into council housing
and there's obviously a very simple
answer but i don't know
well
answers we do sometimes we do but we
also have to buy them yeah
whereas um
obviously we're where they're suitable
they might not always be where we where
we want i mean this is actually more a
question for the cabinet member for
housing yeah i'll pass over to casa
osborne she'll she'll give you a full
answer
well i don't know about a comprehensive
answer but um basically it's every time
properties come forward in a development
on a 106 we bid for those properties
and if they meet with our requirements
and our standards ie are they in the
area that that housing need is
is the standard of the property up to
our usual standard then we will bid we
don't always win those bids that depends
on the developer to select the
successful bidder for those properties
so in that respect we do try very very
hard
to
acquire as many properties as we can
from development but it's not always
possible and it's not always right that
we should do that
does that answer your question
the reason thinking about it was of
thinking about our trying to make
all our homes
of a good standard especially going
forward in terms of carbon reduction and
it's easier to do that if they come
under your
responsibility than if there are third
parties i mean i don't know what
responsibility we have
with housing associations to say you've
got to spend money getting rid of gas
boilers you've got double glazing in
you've got to put solar panels on the
roof whatever we do that with ours but i
bet the housing association don't do
that with us
we do
we are actually putting together a
um a design
policy um but obviously that will be for
houses that we build now the answer to
your question and the most appropriate
answer would be that we build our own to
put into our house in stock but there
the availability of land is the critical
one
and also getting it through planning for
example we had a
application that we put forward to the
planning committee to build five
bungalows for disabled access use
um and it got refused so we're
restricted to
because of the land availability we're
restricted to bid in
on the 106 properties for affordable
housing and there we're in the hands of
the developer on the standards that
they've met obviously we're trying to
guide those standards
but that is down to the planning stage
to make sure that those
properties are up to a
standard thank you castle okay yeah i
mean i think
i'd like it to be included in the uh
discussion later on on housing generally
not today but next time we have a
briefing if we can
consider these things
just just to give you some uh
bare numbers um so far in the current
financial year
um
we have acquired 94
houses um
68 of those are social and affordable
rent because we also provide affordable
rent as well as social rent and 26 of
those are shared ownership
also breaking down that
94
38 were delivered by ourselves
54 were section 106 acquisitions and two
were right to buy acquisitions
so there's there's a good balance there
of of uh houses we
we deliver ourselves and those we we buy
from developers
council mccraw
i just wanted to follow on with that am
i correct and perhaps gavin or
or jan can answer this am i correct that
we're actually shifting our model of uh
housing partnerships
um in the near future
or considering
less use of housing associations and
more uh building in-house
was that have i misunderstood that or is
that a
is that partly true
how much truth is there in that i'm
guessing
yeah it's not really changing the model
of it it's it's acquiring what we can
when we can in the right places for the
right people that's what it's all about
and as i've just alluded to you know the
ideal option would be for us to build
our own houses that would be the ideal
option but it's not feasible because
it's the difficulty in obtaining land to
do so you know you've got big developers
coming forward that have got a lot more
money to buy that piece of land than we
have but that would be the ideal option
so we have to go
with the second best option and that's
acquiring from
developers
and buying off plan
on from that i just had the general
impression that our
partnerships with housing associations
in general
were reducing
or were just i don't know this is what
i'm asking is that correct or not
gathering absolutely help
thank you chair um just to follow on
from from council osborne's point we are
looking to maximize our our own building
capacity
there is an obvious
example that when we look at section 1
106 as a means of increasing our density
or our supply we are in a competitive
bidding process and and clearly through
that process it drives up the the cost
of those units those units of
accommodation are inevitably always
going to get built and always going to
get acquired
so i think through the development of
the business plan what you will see is a
drive and a move towards wherever
practicably possible
delivering new units of accommodation on
behalf of baby residents built by baber
to the highest standards that that can
be afforded and and attributed
and that will be the direction of travel
however there will be challenges along
the way and council of spawn has already
reminded you of the challenges around
around land so that therefore means that
we need to be uh come even small smarter
and more agile in in flight for in terms
of our response
how we make best use of of our existing
land uh to achieve this outcome
thank you gavin
councillor arthi
yeah it's following on really from um
councillor busby's point i think it was
um
just over a year ago that i raised the
point of
the number of council houses that we had
our stock
how much it was increasing through
acquisitions and how much it was
decreasing
through right to buy
and i think it was back in december 2020
um councillor osborne kindly
gave me an answer
but i think that we were going to have
some additional information sent out
which i don't recall was ever done
um with regard to the sort of the
rolling total and the reason that i i
think that might be a good point it
could just be coincidental but at
paragraph 4.4 it says the council's
housing stock is 3 443 homes and that is
exactly the same number that was quoted
in 2020 in paper bca in 1954
where it said the council's housing
stock was 3443
later in the year we were told it was
3418
and that's what prompted my question in
december 2020
you've said that our stock has increased
this year by 94 i find it unlikely that
more than 94 homes have been lost from
our stock through right to buy
so
i think there's
there's still a little bit of clarity
needed about what our housing stock is
and how those figures are updated it
seems to me as though this 3443 could
actually be out of date although it's
quoted as the 31st of march 2021
so i think i'm sure all of cabinet would
probably appreciate
a little bit of detail about what's
happened over the last few years
i think
we quoted back in 2017
a stock of 3505
um
so it would be you know i'm quite
interested and it sounds as though other
people might be quite interested about
actually having some updating on what
our stock is increasing by and why which
you just gave us the information
yourself
but also
what we've lost through right to buy and
what our sort of rolling total is
uh thanks castle arthur uh the right to
buy um
sales i think we're about a dozen in the
past years so um uh we're looking at uh
a net increase of
around about 80. so that you're right
the number 4.4 is out of date it's a
year out of date um but uh i take your
point it would be useful to have a more
detailed breakdown of of the uh uh
losses and gains
yeah well particularly because in the
past we've expressed an ambition to
actually build up our stock again
you know we we keep saying oh we're
we're acquiring these homes we're
providing these homes um some in my ward
in cockfield three bungalows were
provided this year much appreciated
valued um but i think it would be quite
useful to know what's happening it seems
odd to me that we're trucking out the
same figure of three four four three
that we were over a year ago unless of
course it is coincidentally the same
uh i will uh take a look at that and and
uh and uh validate that but uh just to
uh to arrest your uh
reassure you uh council arthi that 94
that i quoted for the current financial
year um in total over the past seven
years the the number uh that we have uh
built and acquired is currently 228
so that's since 2015-16
so it's a significant number so um uh
yeah we need to look at the the overall
total and make sure that is it
accurately reflects what has happened
over the years
thank you
does anyone else have any other points
of debate
in which case uh we'll move to the vote
then henriette can we vote please
members the vote is now in progress on
your app
thank you
chair that's nine votes for that's
unanimous thank you
performance report and i'll now invite
the cabinet member for customers digital
transformation and improvement to
introduce this report
so customer crawl
thank you chair
you have before you the um
regular quarter performance pca 2143
this being
quarter three
um
i don't believe you wish me to go
through each of the infographics on
every page we've all had a perfect
opportunity to examine them i'd just
like if i may to draw your attention to
a few notes um perhaps highlights in
each area but i would always think it's
best if the individual cabinet member
take any question on their own portfolio
with the help obviously of the officers
um so we're looking back at the period
from october to december quarter three
significantly it's the christmas new
year period which brings its own
seasonality um that means the demands
and
requirements change ever so slightly
so this isn't an exhaustive list but it
will give you some indication of the
progress made against our strategic
priorities
um i'm going to draw up maybe one or two
pieces from each sector
in the economy for example the virtual
high street continued to grow with over
1600 vouchers being downloaded over the
christmas campaign
in the environment um this is rather
more negative we saw an increase of 4.85
from the previous quarter of
contaminated recycling waste now we've
got a waste management officer in place
now to review
uh the recycled waste contamination and
develop an action plan to address this
issue it may be that that's seasonal
because of changes of usage in christmas
but i think we need to look into that
it's not a good position to be
contaminating so much of our waste
in the customers portfolio my own i'm
pleased to report that we saw a
reduction in both the abandon rate
of 8
and more significantly a reduction in
waiting times down to 2 minutes 22
seconds that's still not the target we
have which is 1 minute 45 but it's a
heck of a lot better than three and a
half minutes which it had been the
previous quarter
um there are other things in that
portfolio i can add to the chatbot
increase which is something that's
definitely rising and we are rolling the
chat bot out to more and more functions
having started with waste management
our online forms are reasonably well
rated 77 to give them five out of five
and there's an increase in people
choosing to use them
um those are the main ones for that area
i believe
in communities the cctv system has now
been installed with further work being
undertaken with the police to make sure
that areas of towns are monitored and to
identify possibly vulnerable members of
the public
in well-being an event held at hadley
pool and leisure
has been organized for 50 plus
i mean we always talk about
swims for kids but it's nice to see a
rather older
group being catered for as well oh no
i'm sorry i have to say i like swelling
i think it's a very good piece of
exercise
and it's obviously going to help improve
health and well-being
housing has obviously already been
mentioned and i know gavin referred
earlier to the
number of average days to re-let
standard voids uh the housing team are
aware of this but obviously
it's not great at the moment but there
are good reasons for it um health of the
organization we've seen an increase in
the number of days of sickness
we're so a little higher than we should
be
from up to 5.36 days
compared to two other comparable
councils 4.63
and 4.52 however i think that's
something of an outlier in previous
quarters we've usually been under under
the local averages
from memory anyway i'll take any
questions on my own portfolio and direct
any questions for the other portfolios
to that portfolio holder and the
officers if i may
thank you council first of all may i
have a second day for the report
thank you david
council davis your question yeah thanks
um just from the last point that you
made about um staff sickness and in that
particular quarter appreciate it went up
a bit but are you able to drill down a
little bit um
on the mental health aspect of that and
hem and the percentage of staff and
whether that's decreased
who would be the
thing yeah who would be the best person
to answer a question on the health of
the organization
cathy thank you
yes i can confirm that
the numbers of mental health mental
health and sickness absence related
cases has reduced and actually as of
today we have nobody
off sick with
mental health related absence
thank you
counselor arthi
um yeah just questions on a couple of um
points
the items that were mentioned
in the environment report um
for sort of um
scheduled completion after um quarter
three and i think one of them was listed
as january and one as february i just
wonder we've got cassandra clements with
us she can perhaps just update us on
the backwash
water treatment
works at kingfisher
i think they were scheduled to be
completed in january
and the tree canopy survey which i think
originally was going to be available
around about october november time i
think there's a report coming to us on
that which we haven't had yet
just wondered if we could have an update
on when that's expected as well
thank you councillor arthur my colleague
sharon is just checking on the water
filtration system
but i can say in terms of the tree
canopy survey it was delayed there were
some covered delays unfortunately
however we're hoping to bring something
uh to
uh informal cabinet around april time so
we're very close to that being published
now um if you can just give us a second
we might be able to come back to you on
uh water filtration
thanks guys in the meantime does anyone
else have any questions
that's possible
well a general one really um we talked
some time back about improving
communication
we suggested i think i suggested that we
each month we issued one of these
sections
and sent it out to the parish council so
they could they could get a feel as to
what our objectives are
because the stuff that you get they get
at the moment the the monthly reports
are really just news flashes which they
can get off the website
whereas this will see
and tell them what we're trying to do
and what direction we're going in it
effectively means if you've got six
priorities that get
an update twice a year
i think that's a useful suggestion
something we could probably look at uh
captain mccraw do you have a response to
that i think we can examine it i think
with officers and see if it's feasible i
do have one concern about it in that we
say that we age here are dealing with a
series of snapshots on a quarter
and a quarter doesn't necessarily
describe outcomes for the full year
the second point is that we are in the
second quarter of next year going to be
presenting an entirely different method
of presentation
focused on our outcomes
so to use the existing
um
presentation we have now and start
rolling that out when we're about to
change it ourselves seems a little bit
wrong way around i think we could look
though at the outcomes framework perhaps
being communicated to parishes in some
way i'm not entirely convinced
separating it up into just one section
is
i think it could be misleading but i
think it's something we'll discuss
in in the uh in the directorate if
that's okay with you thank you
thank you council davis
yeah um
i seem to recall in the not so distant
past that there was going to be a new
section if you like where the individual
portfolio holders gave more
uh depth and
explanation on their portfolios and i
was delighted to be able to do that for
my communities and well being team
because they do such a fantastic job but
it seems i was the only one that had the
opportunity and hasn't been continued
that that intention at uh council
meetings um is going to continue so
there will be an opportunity for others
to do that at council meetings going
forward
but everyone else will get the same
chance to show off
in the course of the year
okay um
castle barrack
um
it's not really
are we questions or
where are we we're not questions are we
are we on debate
i was only even noticing oh well that's
all right because it's not really sorry
a question um
i i i
i'm trying to sort of get my head around
um where we have customers
as opposed to residents
as a heading
a customer is someone that
buys and has a choice of the service
that they are
providing money for
and i just wonder whether we've got this
terminology correct by saying their
customers it's only it's only a bit of a
technical point but i'm just wondering
you know if you look at this you say
well customer to me a customer is
someone you know comes into your
premises and says can i have our quarter
pound of pear drops please and you say
that is
99p and he says thank you very much and
pays the money and then walks off and
then he has a broken hair drop he comes
back says who's part of this this this
is broken can you replace this bear drop
and um so
then you do that where and then the next
time he goes he goes to a different
sweet shop and buys the difference
because he's had a choice
so
well i am
what i'm saying is
the
is is someone who has a choice where
they're going i don't think the services
that we that we these are statutory
services that we're providing to our
residents
so i i just wonder whether we're using
the right is i'm not really too
concerned about it but i just wonder
when we use the right terminology
saying customers headline performance
indicators or should we say residence
electorate
resident i mean emily you're our legal
person on this one
before i hand over to council mccraw
who's itching to respond uh i will say
that this this this is a debate that um
has been going on for some time and uh
yeah and you're aware of it whether we
call somebody
a resident a customer or indeed a
citizen and and i guess the answer is
there are all three of those depending
on how an individual interacts with us
sometimes they are residents sometimes
they are a customer
but you've got to remember not all of
our services are statutory services some
are discretionary services
so that is the point i will now hand
over to council mccraw
no that's fine i just think it's
something i get asked quite a lot why
why do we call it customers and why do
we have a customer focus
and the simple answer is then having
worked in customer service all my life
uh customer service focused
organizations tend to be more responsive
tend to be more flexible and i mean
there has been evidence proved there
have been studies made on how you
approach things and approaching from a
purely um
what can i call it
bureaucratic viewpoint is not as
effective in serving
the people the residents the the
electors whatever you like to call them
personally i think customers is the
right way to go and organizations that
have provided good customer service tend
to last longer and be more responsive
and i'm happy to defend that position
and i believe that's true officers as
well it's certainly true of the people
who answer our phones because they treat
those people that they speak to as
customers and that is a very important
thing they're not just they're doing
their doing their duty um or fobbing
people off in any way they are there to
be responsive and to treat those people
um as importantly as a customer level
any customer-led organization would do
you look after your customers that's
what you do
thank you we won't
continue this
any further no um
i i just wanted to make a few comments
and the the overall performance
indicators
are all pretty much nearly all of them
heading in the right direction which
which really is good news particularly
given the couple of years we've just had
to go through
i'm very pleased to see that the garden
waste subscribers continues to increase
and that is something i really really
hope the government would take note of
when they
come to
a decision as to whether they're going
to meddle with that service or not
it is uh disappointing that
the contamination of the recyclable
material has increased but um we are
awaiting the resources and waste
strategy
and the impact that's going to have on
on recycling and how that will change
our recycling process so i'm sure we
will be able to
start
addressing that
considerably in the near future
fly tipping down which is good
i know there have been some pretty high
profile flight teaming incidents
reported
in the present on social media recently
but um we are on top of it and um
one incident incident of fly tipping is
wanting many but um we will keep
pursuing this and also where possible um
uh pursuing and prosecuting the
offenders
on the um
the the customers side customers
i'm really pleased also that
our online forms are a success the chat
box
chatbot service does seem to be very
popular and it just goes to show that an
increasing number of our residents do
like interacting with us
online and we're providing the right
facilities to enable them to do that in
an effective way so so that is that is
excellent
so all in all
it's an improving and good position to
be in so i'm i'm pleased with what this
report contains
does anyone else wish to say anything
council osborne
thank you mr chairman um yeah i'd like
to sing the praises for housing because
obviously housing is is very um
very diverse and extremely challenging
however these challenges are always met
face on and there's a commitment from
all the team in housing to improve the
service for example 47 cases of
homelessness has been prevented that's a
fantastic figure if you consider what
they've been subject to under covid and
now coming out of it
close working with landlords we
initiated the central suffolk lettings
that's been really really successful
increasing our housing stock and we i
will be providing members with an
accurate record of what we've got i can
assure you of that
and also if we look at are we doing a
lot on bringing empty homes back into
occupation and also if you look at 81
percent of disabled facilities grants
spent and committed if you compare that
to two two and a half years ago where
only 35 of that budget was being spent
huge amount of work gone on that to
promote that and that's a fantastic
outcome from that so a great deal of
work being done in housing under
extremely challenging circumstances so
well done to all the housing team
thanks mr chairman
thank you
any other comments
oh sorry cass
sorry chair just to come back on the the
second question for councillor
absolutely thank you so yes the water
filtration system went in in january it
was commissioned in february uh we're
waiting our first formal report back but
so far the readings are showing that
it's actually working much better than
anticipated so a higher filtration rate
but i'll get some stats to you outside
of me too
great thank you for that
okay then
council blasphemy you've got to
first of all i'd like to congratulate
john i'm never missing an opportunity to
boost housing team well done
you ought to be marketing manager um i'm
sorry to go back to staff but i kind of
am
um it worries me
particularly on the economic side that
we are missing opportunities by not
having the right
type of staff available
we talk about we've got 20 vacancies i
think it is and we say that it could be
down to um salary
it could be down to
the environment it could be down to a
number of things but
one thing that we don't talk about is
the pool of labor that's available
and if you want to fill your vacancies
without going into a competitive
bidding war with rival councils on
salary you've got to increase the pool
of labor that's available
what are we doing about it in terms of
some of our some of the particular areas
why aren't we sponsoring planning
courses particularly in colleges and
things like that i mean
we need to be more proactive in this
otherwise we'll just end up paying more
and more for less and less
i will
pass over to the chief executive in a
minute but um
you're right we do need to increase the
pool of labour
and it's partly to um
to be able to increase the amount of
training places at colleges or elsewhere
but also of course we need to provide
the homes to attract people to come and
live in the district
if we don't do that then we're never
going to be able to solve that problem
so we need our population to increase
because we have the jobs for them to do
we
we need to build more homes to get more
people to do the jobs anyway pass over
to the chief executive
thank you councilwood um so specifically
on the point you raise councillor busby
about sponsoring for planning courses we
do and we have been for years um so we
both pay to put
our staff through the degrees where they
need to qualify as planners we also send
them on courses we also use
apprenticeships and internships as a way
of developing the next generation
through of course as local government
we've got a real mixture of different
types of roles that we need to feel so
quite specialist planners licensing
officers where there may be a specific
background or even qualification that
people need to have either unique to
local government or more general
and then more general roles where you
don't need to have had a background in
local government at all
and so it's more about your personality
and the skills that you possess the type
of person you are rather necessarily
with the things on your cv in terms of
specific qualifications so we do an
awful lot around developing the next
generation of course even where we do
that we're not the only council doing
that and so you will have seen that over
time um all local governments not
specific to us but all local government
is very good at pinching from fellow
local governments so we've acquired a
number of excellent officers from both
ipswich and cultures during the past for
example they're on our doorstep we're
easily commutable for people who would
have worked there and happy to come and
work across here equally we've lost
people the other way to east suffolk so
it's quite quite a revolving door in
that respect of local government which
is good provides good opportunities but
it does mean that those opportunities
also present a different challenge for
us which is around stability of the
workforce because people are able to to
move on and move up faster so we do need
to make sure that we're providing
better on-site development for people so
there are things we're looking to do in
terms of for example management
development programs for not just
current managers but the next generation
of managers and how we can expand that
but it's a it's a constant battle
particularly as i said earlier in the
current economic position which is a
good place i suppose but not for
employers whereby employees have got a
real choice about where they want to
work whether they are lying to their
cultures their values their salaries the
pensions and everything else that that
staff are potential staff are looking at
but just to give you that reassurance
absolutely are in that space but even
then it is a battle and certain
certain professional areas there is
certainly a
generational gap if you like in terms of
if you look for example are building
control surveyors i'm sure they won't
mind me saying they're all of a certain
age
and so it became
at some point in time it clearly was not
trendy to become a building the job
surveyor and we again that's another
area where we're focusing hard to bring
through the next generation and then
keep doing it so that we don't just
build up a problem for 15 years done
thank you i mean i hear what you say
arthur but it's
if the if the kids today and what the
teenagers today aren't aware of the
opportunities that are potentially going
to become available they don't consider
it
how many people if you ask any 16 year
old
how many would like to be in planning
they'll look you in your face and go
what planning what anything about it
local government is the second largest
employer probably across the country
the second largest employer
what courses what information is given
to the students of today
about local government in general and
all the specific courses and jobs that
are available in it
i'd say none and that's why we're
struggling to get the right kind of
people and as for your revolving door
what happens is we have two vacancies we
poach them off culture so they have two
vacancies they poach them off braintree
so they have two vacancies that's the
revolving door the two vacancies are
continually going round and round and
round we're not feeling it
yeah
i think um fiona you wanted to comment
on that
um
is that working
um
so i think i think you're right and
actually the public sector is a huge uh
employer at national level and we do do
quite a lot so we field teams uh team
members to job fairs not not just in the
district but also wider across across
suffolk and norfolk and we work closely
with the let to
promote the kind of
jobs and careers that we have and one of
the joys of working for the public
sector is you get a really diverse uh
workload and that's the message we've
tried to send out particularly as
recruitment becomes more challenging um
i will just mention the curiosity uh
festival that we held in in stone market
and we're planning to hold shortly in
weber
we're looking at the moment uh later on
in the summer about potentially running
a public sector one where we can exactly
showcase those type of careers that we
know are hard to fill and and get to the
very youngest of of people so that we
can make sure they start to think of
that as a career option
because i have to say it's not really
being classed as a as a career option
but by most people it's something people
fall into or get passionate about uh
later later on in their careers so we're
on it
and
as a final comment on this so we have
got the the democracy project which is
underway
council busby
and through that
part of that is engagement with young
people um on the wider subject of of
local democracy but but also
we can expand that to include this is
what your council does and so give give
them an idea about the various
kind of uh career opportunities so
and i suppose there's
there's always more that can be done to
uh to promote what we do and uh
beyond what what we're already doing but
there's a huge amount that uh as fiona
said that is already going on and you've
got 10 000 students going to college uh
and university
doing media studies in terms of how to
become a disc jockey sorry they don't
call it that any day these days a rapper
or whatever it is for the one job that's
available
and that yeah there are no students
going to college to deal with the
hundreds of thousands of jobs that are
available across the country and local
government
well
schools do have their
advisory services for for students who
are going off to college and university
um and i'm sure that they
those services provide access to
information about all sorts of careers
that they the young people may not
necessarily know about when they're 15
or 16. um so and and local government
and and planning particularly and um
and uh
building control surveying that sort of
thing
will fall into that category but um
it's we're not going to solve it here
today but uh i i take the point you're
making
council baron yeah i'm listening to
coming here on this one because i think
actually the market will get this right
what will happen is rather than and i
think we hit the 50
of uh students going to university i
think what will happen is that um when
you get the opportunity and when the
educational
sector really wake up and start looking
at the vocational qualifications that
you can get in someone like a district
council so you get paid to learn so
ultimately you leave you leave the
school full-time education you join a
council on a program and at the end of
the three years you've got the
equivalent of the degree or whatever and
the whole period you're being paid for
that
that's surely got to be more attractive
than coming out with your 50 000 pound
debt and having a degree which doesn't
actually stand you in any good
employment stand which is what's
happening as go back to your media
studies
but it is it will take time and i think
it is it's the uh a lot of it's doing
the way that the education
still
channels so many people to
university education and that's not
really it's not what the country wants
it's certainly what employers want all
the time
so i think it would just be market and
we can't do it but what we've got to do
is make sure we have those vacancies
at well advertised and we we don't have
a problem filling those vacancies i
assume where we have them
we do have a problem filling the
vacancies purely because there's so many
uh people out there compared to so few
people out there compared to the number
of jobs
about the qualified but the unqualified
the um people coming in on the uh
uh well the nvq world and what course
we're offering but honestly a planning
course which gives you an as a qualified
planning officer out turn
we wouldn't have a problem filling that
course would we
no certainly as long as i would say this
but as long as we are paying
appropriately then we won't have a
problem filling
those roles no absolutely particularly
when people want to
stay local in terms of being able to
deliver things rather than leaving the
district as it were to pursue elsewhere
and
they've got particular values and
behaviours about giving back to
communities
and of course there aren't uh
necessarily the degree courses in being
a local government officer but just to
give another example job planners come
from geography degrees predominantly
they don't have to but there's an awful
lot of jobs that don't need you to go to
university at all to work for us it's
the passion and it's that that we need
that we can help develop once they're
here
we have digressed a bit it's been an
interesting debate but um
okay uh i think that probably wraps it
up for this so this paper is for noting
and we'll move on to the next item which
is item 11 paper bca2144 climate change
and biodiversity annual report
2021-22 and i'll invite the cabinet
member for climate change to introduce
the report council marissa
thank you very much chair it gives me
great pleasure to introduce bdc's first
annual climate change and biodiversity
report
which is more commonly referred to as
the environment report
biodiversity affects us all whether we
like it or not and climate change also
correcting the loss in biodiversity will
go a long way to benefit climate change
because it's a kind of chicken and egg
situation the one is dependent on the
other and vice versa
however i recognize that there are those
among us who shall we say are not keen
on this green thing
and i hope this annual report will show
just how intertwined we all are in
climate change and biodiversity
so much so that it reminds me of the
poem by john dunn no man is an island he
writes about isolationism
and how everything is interconnected
which is why i believe that this report
should continue to be presented to you
and the residents of babur on an annual
basis
putting together such a report
demonstrates how everyone has pulled
together on the common theme of
improving our biodiversity net gain and
its eventual contribution to climate
change
it's been a long
arduous journey
but enjoyable
one that started back in 2019
with the declaration of the climate
emergency quickly followed by the action
plan on biodiversity
but the awards and achievements as you
can see since then a testament to the
commitment of this council and all
involved in getting us
there
but especially to cassandra clements and
her entire team
i therefore recommend that this report
be noted
and the cabinet agrees that the report
should be produced annually
thank you
thank you counselor may i have a second
to please counselor arthi
questions anyone
any questions on this report
okay oh castle dawson
yeah i do yet
um
to what the budget sort of really was
what it's you know expected to be any
ideas of whether we're going to generate
any income and what the costings are
going to be off this yet
thank you counselor
it's not been worked out yet
but you'll get more information on that
if you'd read the report on the gas
emissions
because
there is a school of thought
that
we will be trading in
i'm looking to i'm looking at cass
because i can't remember the
name for the thing
carbon credits
are you talking about right could be
carbon credits
the same with
with trees as well
yeah so if i come on to the point that
liz i think you're making is the work
that we've done around the tree surveys
will give us um
uh data that will
enable us to understand the financial
pressure of trees not just
the sequestration so when we're talking
about new developments and trees are
being taken away we'll know financially
what needs to be replaced not just a
number of trees for instance so it will
take into account their age and their
sequestration rate so i think that's
what liz is talking about in terms of
money back in
the one thing that has been done so far
was moving our leisure centres over to
green tariffs and the filtration systems
so they will have brought about savings
although clearly they are for our
partners as opposed to us however there
is likely to be
reduced management fees in the in the
future because they'll see their bills
coming down what i will just give is a
word of warning clearly the current
crisis around fuel and the um
the happenings with russia and ukraine
at the moment there's clearly lots of
work going on to remove links to
russian fuel like gazprom so we just
need a bit of word of caution about that
um
we don't have anything currently
underway that sees a return to the
council but that's purely on the the
current plan it doesn't mean that
there's nothing coming forward
roughly what is what is it we predict to
spend on this in the next year
taking into account
what's happening globally there must be
a sort of proxy
sure so within the plans there are
around
200 to 300 000 pounds worth of spend due
to come in the next financial year
clearly that isn't that's far more than
what's in the environment reserve
currently but the team
environmental protection team and
environmental management team have been
excellent so far in securing external
funding and that will be our first port
of call for anything um that we can't
you know so we uh are using money where
we can from our own purse but we're
utilizing all of the public funding
that's available to us as well
thank you castle davis
yeah thanks uh first of all i think it's
an excellent report it's really in depth
um i'm one of those people although not
um
sort of carrot eating
toad sand or open toes or whatever you
know i do understand the importance of
being green and i live on and i believe
and i live on uh you know one of the
council is fortunate enough to live on
the most beautiful part of baby district
council so we
we understand the importance of
a being green the environment and
everything that entails but what i would
ask because again living on the
shoreline peninsula we do have an issue
in terms of public transport um and and
i noticed there is reference in here too
you know the bus back better scheme but
i don't know if councilman vasey's be
able to give us a little bit more
reassurance about that and also the
progress that's being made in terms of
walking and cycling routes
thank you council council movies are you
able to respond
better
there is i think the public consultation
is finished and there's a report due to
come out
um
bus back beta is mostly dependent on
county
but there is a push to have local run
around buses
thank you very much
well go start
is an example
but what we need to do is to turn these
small runaround buses into electric
vehicles
or take a leaf out of aberdeen's
[Music]
book and have hydrogen run
which
buses
my opinion my personal opinion would be
far far better
fast do you want to add anything to that
nothing at this point but just to say
i'm happy to talk to our sustainable
travel officer and particularly about
the peninsula but also the bus back
better scheme and get an answer to you
outside of the meeting
and and on the cycling walking
infrastructure plan um
that will
um is yeah and it's going to certainly
on the peninsula there are a number of
uh cycleways that are in existence
already um but the existing ones aren't
proposed but they they're not all
interconnected yet but um uh i think one
of the the aims is is to be able to have
a far more joined up approach to those
so that
there is a more comprehensive network
and you can get from shopee to ipswich
effectively or shortly to brantham
effectively which i know would be
of huge benefit on the
peninsula council sorry i've worked a
lot with with them
other councillors and developers on
producing that because it's been a long
time in the making and and we are
getting closer yeah the shortly to
charlemagne chamber to wolveston the
wolvestone to holbrook yeah the freshman
bit so there are still but but it's a
case of you know we need to be
a little bit sharper i think not just on
the shortly peninsula but through the
whole district yeah and one of the
things obviously with uh introducing the
car parking chargers was that was going
to be a part of
of the walking and cycling routes within
that so the sooner we implement the car
parking charges the better
capsule macro we won't talk about
parking anymore i wasn't going to
actually but i would want just wanted to
draw um
councillor melvici and officers
attention to the fact that the hydrogen
bus scheme uh in aberdeen which is all
the aberdeen municipal buses um there's
a published report available on that on
the internet which i've i've had a
glance through worth a look anyway i
think you can probably get more detail
and i'd suggest that with the way things
are going at the moment
hydrogen might in turn out to be rather
more economic than it had looked in the
past
that's that's a fair point yeah yes
okay are there any questions cassarthy
yeah this question for you really given
the links between the parking strategy
and the carbon reduction management plan
um
do these two now fall in different
portfolios
yes
they do because um
the carbon reduction management plan is
part of our climate change portfolio
which is castle malvesi
and the parking strategy still
resides under the
residual environment portfolio along
with
other environment services such as waste
and that's castle dawson
i thought so
it wasn't a try for anything at all
okay questions council buzzer you've got
a question
or are we moving moving into debate we
can move into debate now i think good
idea yes
um one of the points we're talking about
in tree and hedgerow planting in 2019
the committee on climate change
announced the need
to plant 30 000 hectares
of trees each year each year
30 000 hectares
each year nationally yeah and 30 000
hectares it's about 65 000 acres
and i reckon you probably get probably a
thousand trees on there but maybe at
least a hundred so you're looking at
what 650 000 trees and we
in the greenish part of the uk have
planted 281
it's not getting us very far to the
third to the 30 000 hectares is it
if you're not sorry surrey's greener
than suffolk
but not all of that 30 000 hectares is
public land it's going to be a lot of
private land there so
in terms of
the point you're making though is that
we we've got to do better yes and and i
don't think any of us would deny that um
we're just we've just started on on this
process um
and uh it's it's something that is going
to uh to build up and we'll be working
with our communities um
uh with with landowners uh to to ensure
that the tree planting in baba does uh
uh provide its its due
share of of that uh thirty thousand per
annum
we don't have the land
we don't know but uh others there are a
lot of there's a lot of uh grants
available to private landowners
um
to create their own
green canopy
sorry for 30 000 trees it's thirty
thousand
trees i think we've got a target of ten
thousand trees haven't we
i thought it was ten thousand trees
baber
i'm sure we have that as one of our
targets
accountability yes do we have a specific
target for ourselves as a district or
for
our ambitions for the district as a
whole so we've set our ambition to say
that we want to
bring in a tree management strategy
which includes planting we haven't given
ourselves or have been given a figure
for that what i will just bring our
attention to though is that um firstly
we've had
the really successful launch of the
parish and town council project in terms
of trees and the response from them has
been absolutely wonderful and a
particularly passionate response i'd say
to giving up areas of their land to tree
planting so that's happening um
currently now we've just um
employed our biodiversity project
officer who's going to take that on as a
project themselves so it's got its
dedicated resource as well so i know
there was a probably unexpected response
actually uh that overwhelmed the public
realm team slightly uh but we'll get
back on track with that so fantastic
response from them and also that
generated quite a few contacts from
private land owners saying that they
wanted to put
their private land over to trees so
we've managed to put them in touch with
places that have got um grants for that
kind of work as well so lots going on at
the moment in terms of tree planting
it's definitely just the start of our
journey
thanks guys councillor osborne from
little acorns thank you mr chairman um i
think this is an excellent report and i
fully support it one of the things that
we do need to consider is as we move
forward five six seven eight years ahead
the maintenance of those trees that
we're planting and the hedge cutting you
know we've got trees in sudbury for
example that cost a lot of money to
maintain them even on a rotating basis
so we do need to take that into
consideration
in regards to cycling and walking i
think we need to look more locally at
what's already coming forward or already
available now for example in
sudbury we have the gainsborough trail
we've already put the first section of
that the sudbury section in and the
chilton section is to be opened um in a
few months time
but funding
isn't there for us so i think district
and county need to look where they're
putting their funding for example
to suggest a cycle route
um where they've done it for melford
road is absolutely crazy
but that's where they're prepared to put
their funding whereas they could put
their funding into the games betrayal to
make it really walkable really cycle
proof as well and that's where we need
to look little be a little bit more
proactive with where we're putting the
funding in regards to what's coming
forward and what's already there
available locally
thank you mr chairman
thank you council councilman crawl
i could just respond to that because
it's a very good point the um like local
cycling walking and infrastructure plan
lc whip um the group we've been working
on that for the last few months have
just completed um the draft report and a
little bit of tidying up to do
and we are now prepared to send our lc
whip on to suffolk county council
this is a government initiative
taking place across the country we've
been operating two members of this
cabinet in fact sit on the lc whip body
and it's now coming to a conclusion
costs can be high but we've basically
managed to come up with
and with the help of very good officers
and you'll note in the report we have a
specific officer dedicated to this very
subject so we are
if you like putting the resources to it
that's been supplied the money for that
has been supplied by central government
um but we're making use of it that's
ready to go forward and we have to
integrate it with the overall suffolk
plan but baber mid suffolk being a
significant part of suffolk uh that
should all integrate and we should see i
would hope some action taking place
later this year
thank you for that update council macro
okay um
i can add it will be coming the lc whip
report will be coming to this cabinet
and we've also agreed that it should go
to
uh that's for
not ratification i suppose approval is
what we'll be looking for and then after
that just for information um to be noted
by the council and this has been
discussed just just this last week
thank you
i i think this is an excellent report as
well i'm i'm particularly pleased with
appendix b the greenhouse gas emissions
report the the breakdown of of data
about our emissions there is is
excellent and also we'll be able to see
um
how how those emissions are reducing uh
so that we
will meet our 2030 target
of uh zero emissions which um
uh
is is ultimately what this is all about
um so i think i'm very pleased with this
first report and i look forward to
seeing it again next year and in the
years to come
if there are no further
comments from from anyone then i'll
now open up the the vote for this
henry can we start the vote please thank
you chair members the vote is now in
progress
counselor dawson
thank you
uh chair that is
eight votes for and one vote against
thank you
thank you for that
right moving on to the final item on
today's agenda item 12 paper bca2145
the response to national grid statutory
consultation on the brantford to twisted
overhead line project
i'll now invite the cabinet member for
planning to introduce this report
council arthi
thank you chairman it's quite simple
really
we've
all had the opportunity to attend
various
briefing events that's cabinet and
all of the other councillors on the
council
we've got a response
proposed for you here
and it's really just for you to
agree or amend as necessary
thank you
thank you arthi um any questions anyone
councillor barrett you know when this
came before us sorry i need a second oh
right
yeah sorry
do you mind if i carry on
um
we had some recommendations
of the
proposals um which were to continue i
think with the recommendation which was
the undergrounding and then over
grounding the underground within the amb
on the twinsted sorry on the
branford to
sort of levin heath and then
under the oamb coming up and then going
on the other section on the star valley
is that is that basically what we're
looking to recommend here or
uh yes yes it is it's not in the
recommendation because there was a like
an a b
one two or three so i just wonder
whether
that would have been
slightly stronger if we'd have had the
there was there was basically three
options that were shown in the report
and i thought we were going to just
trying to firm up on the option that we
felt was the
preferred option and i think we all
agreed on it i think the uh
yeah we got we've got the draft
responses as the appendix um and and
that does uh refer to undergrounding as
council arthur says on page 131 and
specifically on page 133
it talks about the um
the removal of the um
the current 132 kv line uh through the
devon vale and also um down at silver
valley um
we've we've talked about other things
that we
in this report that we want to see
national grid uh address as well as that
so
the question is
do we
believe that this the response as it
currently stands
um is one we want to submit do we want
to add anything to it do we recommend
anything
i think the response is fine um it's
just that when we were
it could have been easier because there
was the the three recommend the three
positions that came forward
and we haven't really i mean he's
identified by
uh the fact that but i wonder whether we
could be a bit more specific and say
this one by three you mean uh
keep everything over the ground put
everything from bradford to twins it
underground no or there was the option
that the national grid came up they they
had their own options within the paper
that was presented
and those options was
one they were listed weren't they
and i just wondered whether we would be
better if we
i'm quite happy to leave it to the the
ad to to sort it out but i just wanted
we
it was quite clear
the options available
which was the one that was the preferred
route i think by
national grid and the only thing that
they weren't doing which we wanted to do
was to take out the 132 line
they were going to leave that they were
going to leave that in position and i
think we definitely wanted that taken
out they are
um because the the second 400 kv line
was to replace that 132 right um and in
sections where it uh won't be going
underground then the 132 by necessity
has to come down so the new 400k v can
be put up um but to where it crosses the
air and b and where it goes through the
silver valley then uh the 132 will come
down
where where is the place with
underground sections okay i mean yeah
easy
does anyone else have any questions
counselor dawson
about this it really isn't clear it's in
the areas where it's going through the
areas aonb
in those areas
um if there are the pylons going through
the issues doesn't seem to be addressed
um
where you can see the pylons when you're
in an area of air and b and really when
you're in that area
that's the whole point of it you
shouldn't be able to see anything and i
don't think that's been analysis has
been done of that it seems quite clear
to me
that well that's that's the whole
purpose behind putting it underground so
that it won't be visible yes but in
parts
you know some of the areas um
i'm just concerned that if there's an
aonb next to an area where it isn't
that transition
there are going to be has enough
analysis being done and my understanding
is it hasn't been when i was asking
questions you can still see when it
starts to go pylons above ground that
those are visible when you're in an area
for aonb and that kind of i would have
thought isn't really acceptable
well that's not really what this uh any
of this was
designed to address it was designed
specifically to address the visual
impact within the aomb
itself
i understand the point you're making you
know if you're standing for it well i
don't know i'm going to bend but if
you're standing in an area and i don't i
don't know exactly but you know places
like benton end or going across the
stair valley if you if you're standing
and you can see these pylons when you're
in the a and b that would suggest to me
that it's
you know more should be underground
surrounding those areas which i don't
think has happened um
i i think that that would kind of
suggest
a full undergrounding of the whole run
simply no no i know i realize if you're
standing in an aonb in many places you
can have a sight line of 10 15 miles and
you'd still be able to see bylaws and
and
so trying to uh address that would would
not really be feasible but i take the
point you're making
councillor davis yeah thanks um as the
jc aj ac member
for baber on the aomb um for both both
dead and vale and the soviet coastal
news i can assure councillors that
a rigorous process has taken place with
consultation the aomb has made their
position very clear
uh in terms of what they would like to
see in the twinsted to branford
pylon run
so uh everything has been done and said
um they've spoken with um
[Music]
with all the energy suppliers uh
involved and so
complete due process has been followed
and uh
and i could say our thoughts have been
very much accepted
by the uh by the energy companies and
and james cartilage as well
thank you councillor
casarthy
yeah i i accept the point that councilor
dawson has made and i think it's a good
point um it was made quite early on
um and that's the the point about um the
impact on the aonb also involves views
from within the aonb out and from
outside the aonb into the aomd
and it was those early concerns i think
that led to the proposals being changed
slightly where the ceiling end compounds
which are a quite large
um areas of land and quite large
structures um would be moved rather than
be on the edge of the aomb they were
further out of the aomb so that the
impact on the aomb wasn't so great and
there is a small part where instead of
crossing the aomb
um the proposals now go around a sort of
a a
sticking out block of aomb
i think it's worth saying that none of
this is ideal well apart from the
removal of existing lines
because there is an impact with
underground as well it's it's not a
no-impact solution
because you will end up with a
effectively a scar on the landscape and
it's the landscape you're seeking to
protect
where there will be
no buildings
nothing higher than a hedge i think it
will be an identifiable scar on the
landscape
but
really we're stuck between sort of two
extremes one is we could say no we don't
want them at all um and that's not going
to get us anywhere at all um or we could
say well we've got pylons at the moment
um
you know
undergrounding is a scar
just like pylons
but i i think what we're trying to do is
minimize
the impact so that's that's um
saying that undergrounding has less of
an impact than pylons above the ground
and if we can get the ceiling end
compounds as far away from the aomb
boundary as possible that's an advantage
and if we can
reduce the area that has any power lines
at all whether they're underground or
overground by going around the aomb then
that's an advantage as well so i mean
i don't think we can take a position
where um we don't agree with anything at
all
it's i think it's a matter of having to
accept that it's the least bad option
yeah
yeah um i attended um the national good
exhibition at the hadley town hall
last weekend and
they were very very uh helpful they had
a lot of people there
and i had a long chat with experts about
all aspects of it the ceiling end
compounds
the
construction and
repair of landscape following trenching
i also spoke to an expert there on
electromagnetic field emissions
and the differences between uh those
from uh overhead wires and under
underground cables and um how the
attenuation of those fields with
distance um uh differs between the two
solutions so that they were the
national grid
are trying to do their best to give as
much information as possible so i would
urge anyone who wants to to find out to
go along to one of these exhibitions and
talk to the people there you'll get a
huge amount of information from experts
there's lots of printed material
from my point of view
this ceiling and compound issue is is
one that i do want to raise and i think
that our report
i would like to see our report
specifically addressed and that is the
eastern ceiling end compound of the aomb
which is currently uh cited or due to be
cited impulsed
it um
there was an initial location um which
national grid have have moved
following um a consultation with the
parish
um
but the the new site is still not ideal
it is right next to a very attractive
woodland bluebell woodland access along
a very narrow lane is not not ideal
and pollsted parish council and i agree
with them
will
do want national grid to reconsider and
and look at a third alternative location
and that is the old disused layer and
quarry pit because the the landscape
there is such that um
it automatically offers
seclusion and
cuts down on the visibility of that
ceiling and compound um from a distance
whereas the the earlier two locations
don't that it would have been visible
from from quite a long way off um
despite uh potential
screening that they proposed with tree
planting the other
factor to consider is that land quarry
site is located by a bespoke and
purpose-built road from the a1071 a nice
wide and straightened road which will
allow the construction traffic easy
access
so
for all those reasons it would mean
an extension of probably a half a mile
or so of underground cabling but
in terms of the mitigation of the impact
on the countryside of the ceiling
compound
i would like to see us make a strong
statement
to to propose that well to recommend
national grid that
they consider this this third location
does anyone have any objections if if we
were to put words to that effect in in
our consultation response
just one little problem and that is that
you specified the lion pits and i don't
know if necessarily we should mention
that
because it may not be a suitable
location but certainly in the area of
lay and pit is is what you're saying
in the area of land pitch then
thank you council rothie
does anyone else have anything uh the
counselor
in the area of lay and pit but not my
back garden thank you
um yes i have my hour session with the
experts next this friday at henderson
i'm looking forward to that i understand
the word they say but there you go
um i'm a bit disappointed in the report
in a way because i don't think it's it's
strong enough
uh
if somebody suggested that we built an
m1
six lane
highway between i don't know
shockley and
wherever
cambridge
we'd kind of we would say what what you
know you wouldn't put a scar like that
across beautiful suffolk but here we are
we're sticking these thinking great big
pylons
and there are a lot of them across the
area we're not going to benefit from
this at all and where does it stop we've
had one lot of pylons and then because
we had the fir we had the first lot it's
all right to put a second lot up
and now we're talking about another run
from king's lynn down to essex so there
we go oh it's they've got pylons there
already we'll stick another pylons up
this is not acceptable for this
particular area this doesn't mention
anything about under under the sea i
don't think i couldn't find it in this
report and bearing in mind that a lot of
the energy that we're generating comes
from either size well or offshore
why are we bringing it onshore
to take to transport it why isn't it
going down
under the sea
you can raise that when you speak to
national grid
um but there are technological as well
as well as financial challenges to that
because of the uh sheer amount of um
electricity that that is going to be
transported
you've got to
you've got to understand that um
with sizable and offshore i think the by
2050 something like that about
30 percent of the uk's energy needs will
have to come
from suffolk or off off the suffer coast
the the north sea wind turbines in this
area by 2050
um are expected to generate
something just a bit short of 40
gigawatts of electricity a massive
amount
yeah but that that's that's that's their
potential capacity but we need to look
at
the amount of electrical energy that
we're looking at um over the next 20 30
years
it's a it's a huge amount
and and that's set in the context of i
think that our total generating capacity
in the country at the moment is only
about 50 60 gigawatts something like
that so um
electricity requirements are going to
increase by a huge amount and simply
because we're moving away from other
other fuel sources
and and most of that or a lot a huge
part of that is coming through suffolk
and that and and um
there are benefits of that because
it's going to be hugely beneficial for
the suffolk economy jobs
and technology in the county but um
the the downside is that there has to be
um
the infrastructure to transport that uh
energy to where it's needed and um we're
on the route between the north sea and
london the north sea and midlands
we just got to
work with this and um and and
and agree options that that mitigate as
far as possible the impact on on our
countryside but the
the solutions are there they can
put
the energy down underneath the sea
because they do it
it's just
a little bit more expensive perhaps than
it is than sending it through dear old
suffolk bit or stick be quite happy to
have all these pylons everywhere there
are technology challenges as well
in terms of
the amount of uh
electrical energy that
is it's down one pipe perhaps
um council macro
para4 i think pretty much sums up where
i stand on this and i can see that i
guess nobody likes overhead cables um
but they exist they have existed and
they will exist as long as people
need electricity because there are
actually
quite a number of reasons why
you don't bury every cable under the
earth in fact um
if uh uk pound networks have a break in
the overhead lines
that's one thing but uh fixing a brake
underground is a great deal more
difficult and actually contains
considerable risk to the operatives
doing so yeah doing it
no they do actually break underground i
know because
i can state this quite firmly because
i've worked in the control center that
deals with such breaks in the
transmission so i can state that
categorically that it happens
um
however if we look at this overall we
have an additional
19 kilometers of new 400 kilowatt
overhead lines but we are removing
well the consultation is
and a half
of um assorted sizes and the difference
of course is that the two and a half of
that 27.5 is 400 kilovolt the same size
the same capacity 25 kilometers is
kilovolts and it seems fairly clear to
me is that we're upgrading the carrying
capacity of the lines and that is
required simply because energy
requirements across the country are
rising we're not making we're not
developing this energy offshore
uh for no purpose it's going to go to
houses and people do want that energy
um we are gaining 10 kilometers of
underground cables through the aonb
areas it's capped at both ends and it
exists outside the ends the net effect
i believe is positive
no no i'm just saying but that's the
thing up so the net effect is we're
leaving officers flexibility to make our
response on these broad principles the
assistant director in collaboration with
the cabinet member for planning will
consider any proposed amendments and all
these points we've put in
are towards that effect so effectively
we are delegating the authority
and to those two people to to make the
amendments and i'm quite happy to
support that i don't think we can do
much more without arguing in circles
thank you girl
yeah
that's um that's that's all so if nobody
else has anything there oh cancer dawson
yes i'm just
have they done my understanding and
perhaps council answer might be a chance
there seems to be lack of economic
cost analysis for whole life comparisons
and the area i was thinking about was
say between
11 heath and viewers over 50 years have
they calculated what the difference in
costs would be
you know to that say
small specific areas i
i'm concerned about that particular area
not just my ward but
whether a life comparison cost has been
made which i think they should be
yeah that's something that uh uk power
networks would undoubtedly have have
worked out in in their um
analysis of the
the solution options but it's not
something that our officers would if we
just said it's acceptable can we not
sort of stay in that particular area
where it is an area of outstanding
national beauty what is the can they
give us an idea
we shouldn't really be accepting it
readily should we and
for what purpose
well because if it's over 50 years the
same cost then we'd have it underground
rather than having pylons so they are
putting it on the ground
but within the store valley section uh
and also the aomb section so it'll be
underground through polsted as far as
just the the eastern part of levan heath
the b10
exactly
yeah this is that's where it comes out
yeah
it's overground
just off the b1068 at that um uh harris
street part of eleven heath yeah
councilman crawl underground cabling is
a great deal more expensive than
overhead and there's been shown to be
some many many years and i realized that
the point i'm trying to make here sorry
mike
before i
you didn't so i'm sorry guys yeah
well
my question hasn't been answered
um or has it been was there an economic
cost analysis
um for a whole life cost comparison
in an area such as between 11 heath and
little cornard where it is going
overground i i don't know that's what
i'm asking
but my understanding is it has not been
done and this is a flaw in part of this
well i i the answer is i don't know
because there was never any uh
suggestion or option to underground that
particular section it was never a
consideration
well i don't know i counseled artie's in
charge are you seeing this and you might
be able to answer rather than yourself
okay
would you would you like to yeah i mean
i'm not in charge of it at all i mean
you're responsible for whatever response
you want
and
our leader has already suggested a
slight amendment to what's proposed
i i will agree that that that is the
response with with the ad responsible
tom who's not here today
um
so i mean i'm by no means um an expert i
have i have attended um all of the
sessions that have been provided and
when i referred earlier on
to the changes that have been made since
the initial consultation and i don't
know how many of these sessions you've
you've attended
the last one that we had
was
not very long ago actually was it last
week or the week before
and um they've
changed quite a lot since then and i was
just going to read you from their
presentation
what they said had changed
so that they
their headline for it was you said we
did
and there are a number of bullet points
they confirmed undergrounding in the
dead and vale aonb and the star valley
project area
we confirmed a greater amount of
undergrounding overall i mentioned
earlier on that they they were now
avoiding a small area of the omb
completely by going around it
a change to the route and configurations
of pylons around brantford substation
consideration of a further routing
option around hindustan and ramsey woods
an alternative route of undergrounding
to the east of the dedham vale
alternative route of undergrounding in
the store valley
relocation of three cable end ceiling
compounds and that's what john was
talking about earlier on he was talking
about the move of the one in pollsters
and considers it hasn't actually been
okay sorry
um a further reduction i've just got two
more points that they put in there in
their presentation further reduction of
the existing 400 kilovolt line running
south from prince twinsted t
and greater use of full tension gantries
at the ceiling and compounds
to reduce the number of terminal pylons
yeah okay so those are the changes that
they've made since the initial
consultation which is albeit some time
ago now wasn't it the the original
consultation
sorry
sorry friday it's still it's still yeah
there's the public sessions on friday so
there are still options for individuals
too there are contributions
last
friday
in
public consulates and i went with them
that's why i'm asking this question
because i was told that this should be
brought up here this afternoon
that's why i'm asking you
sorry who suggested who told you
when i went along and spoke with them on
friday in terms of the um
yes and i was asking specifically about
lavenhead to um
to uh little corner there which is an
area or it's just the pile of aonb area
and that area i believe is underground
and i was asking them um and they were
saying this was the sort of thing that
could be brought up today
um and should be noted i don't know
whether we could perhaps you know rather
than just accepting that it's a given
that all of this is and i understand a
lot of it has to go underground which i
do overground i mean i do understand
that but i just feel in this
particular stretch we should be pushing
to try and get it underground because of
where it is but it's not in the aomb no
but when you're in the aonb you can see
it and so therefore it's
exactly i think so okay so castle
awesome you you want us to make a second
amendment to this paper to
to relate to that yes i think
the little corner section and that goes
underground because it's visible from
the aim yes that is the point you're
making yes right and has a cost analysis
a whole life cost
whole life cost comparison being made
um because you'd probably find over 50
years
um you know it's not going to be
actually probably that much more over 50
year period it might be a lot more i
really don't know
but that's the sort of thing we should
be rather accepting it we should be
pushing
in this particular area um you know i
just you know i'm not parochial over
hadley but i can see quite clearly
this particular area here we want to try
and ensure that we maintain it
council mccraw
i'm just a bit bemused why uk power
network send you to ask weber officers
to answer a question that they can only
they can answer like what the 50-year
cost would be it just seems to me a bit
no no i don't think it overheals yeah i
think what council dawson is saying that
um uh
uh
it's
things like this can be put into
consultation responses and if we wanted
uh a statement in our consultation
response then then she needed to to
raise it with us now today which is a
fair point so just be clear chairman the
area that we're talking about i think
the area that council councillor dawson
is talking about is the area from
the ceiling end compound
um on the western end of the aonb
which is lebanese
and
the currently proposed overhead line to
what i think is little corner street
viewers yeah the store valley east cable
ceiling and compound
where it pops underground again
so you're talking about the length um
basically that goes through assington
um
that's currently proposed overground and
you're saying that
or you're asking why that length
couldn't be completely i just think we
should ask them to consider it it's
quite a large area i've explained my
reasons it seems okay yeah i haven't i
mean i must admit i haven't heard that
question asked um at any of the sessions
that i've attended i don't know if you
attended any of the sessions two days
ago yes sorry yes two days ago and did
you ask the question yes
so what castle dawson wants is is for
the uh the two underground stations to
be why didn't you just sort of say yes
well i don't know why we're making such
an issue about it it's just a really
straightforward point i'm trying to make
here you know as i think council
basketball said we shouldn't really be
accepting the sort of plowing of all
this through areas of a and b i'm not
quite sure what the argument is again
it's you know they might not put it in
but if they do it's to our benefit
because we don't want to ruin these
beautiful areas do it's crazy i think
the way to to phrase this do we want a
second amendment that
requests
the two sections of underground um
line to be uh joined together so that
there's a continuous underground line
from east of the uh aomb through to west
of the store valley
because the the uh the bit in the middle
is visible from from both of those
protected areas
and consequently by putting the whole
run underground that would improve that
visual impact from within
the two protected areas
that's not unreasonable it's not
uh and i think um our
the residents who on the verge of the
aomb and this is the point council doors
are making
they're still seeing it the fact is not
in an aonb
it impacts the air will be on its
official thing and certainly in planning
um visual impact on an air b is
something that we take into
consideration we do
so that's that's that's a perfectly sort
of valid point so i think if we could
just find some wording just to
put in there i think it would be
sensible to take that approach i mean
it's not
is it likely to that it would form but i
think from our
from our residents there
that's what sure they would expect us to
put in
i think you're right councillor osborne
yeah i don't i don't see a problem with
that however
my concern is obviously when we go
underground um there can be some impacts
on those particular communities so i
think in regards to this particular area
um i think we need to know if it was to
go underground what would the impact be
on that particular area by doing it you
know we only had that discussion a few
months ago where yeah it's great put
everything underground that would be
that would be the
best solution however there are impacts
to putting them underground as well as
going overground so i think we need to
make that clear in in our response yeah
all of the communities have construction
traffic um implications and and um
there'll be the construction of hall
roads across countryside during the
construction of the underground trenches
but those whole roads will will then be
removed
so um
the impacts um are not inconsiderable
but they are temporary
counselors can we just be clear about i
mean i know you haven't put it to a vote
yet but just be clear about what this
proposal is because the current proposal
is that after the underground section
through the aonb
there is then a new 400
kilovolt overhead line
routed to the south of the existing 400
line
okay
replacing
the existing 132
so i'm not quite sure what we're
suggesting here are we suggesting that
the existing 400 can stay
and that there should then be an
underground 400.
yeah that's what's happening
alongside it or something that's what's
happening through the aomb and the store
valley
is that what's happening
and what council dawson is requesting is
that that um
uh happens also in the section between
the two proposed underground sections so
there is one continuous underground run
effectively from posted to to viewers
um we've got to we have to remember you
you've raised an uh interesting point we
have to remember that the existing 400
kv lies will remain they will not at any
point along the route be removed no
you might as well put two lines down
there uh you'd have to dig a wide a
strange twice as wide already
you have to have separation underground
anyway
i think can we uh we've pretty much had
a um a good debate about this i think
what we'll put to the vote is uh the the
paper we have with the two proposed
amendments and that um
uh councillor arthi will work with bronn
and also me because i got the wording
for the ceiling compound one um to have
the final wording for an amended paper
can we can we say that what we're
looking at is that we're asking them to
reconsider um the sighting
of um the posted ceiling and compound
and we're also asking them to reconsider
um the possibility of undergrounding
between the two cylinder compounds
um where um to the west of the aonb
that's 11 heath one um going down to
little corner yeah yeah correct
i think
we've got a principle established that's
where we stand and i think we need to
justify okay
doesn't need to come back anymore
we'll now put that to the vote please
henry
thank you chair the vote is now in
progress on your app
councillor busby
thank you
cheers
eight votes for
thank you
okay thanks everyone uh that brings
today's meeting to a close uh the next
meeting scheduled for the 4th of april
at 2pm
you